it's the mid
90s there's a new president in the white
house it was a very very positive time
and he seemed to embody it the economic
boom is in full swim optimism creativity
possibility the internet is taking hold
of Our
Lives all these amazing radical changes
are
underway life is good I just happen to
be in the right place at the right
time our whole job was just trying to
make each other
laugh but on the horizon storm clouds
are gathering ready to blow America
apart we had no idea what was on the way
it was absolutely
frightening
it would become a symbol and an
inspiration the federal government
versus the people complete with Jack
Boots black helicopters and illegal
Weaponry wakeo was the power of a cult
wo counterbalanced that with the awesome
Fierce power of federal law
enforcement what can go go
wrong the United States government
essentially instigated an act of Terror
against citizens of the United States of
America that's
[Music]
wrong Waco Texas a small town that until
1993 was best known for its historic
Steel Bridge and being the birthplace of
Dr
Pepper High School Dropout out and
wannabe rock singer David Kesh now has a
new ambition he claims to be the Son of
God and in a compound on the outskirts
of town this would be Messiah is
collecting followers Revelation states
that Christ has the Key of David there's
150 Psalms
here some people find it amazing that I
know every one of
[Music]
them
mostly in their 20s and 30s from middle-
class backgrounds these True Believers
are united by a search for meaning in
their lives and they truly believe David
Kesh has the answers is he the Son of
God I hope he is what would I do for
him I love him as a
[Music]
brother the branch devidians believe the
apocalypse is coming and they are busy
stockpiling illegal weapons including
AK-47s worried about the amount of guns
the cult are accumulating the
ATF decide to raid the
compound so confident are they of
success agents nickname The Raid
Showtime but Kesh and his cult members
are
expecting
[Music]
they knew that the ATF was coming they
had all taken their Battle Stations they
had more powerful Weaponry one ATF agent
described it as a hail storm in
Reverse it looked like a dust off from a
fire zone in Vietnam with a Medevac
helicopter coming in to pull people out
it was chaos it was very very
disturbing four ATF agents are killed in
the raid and five Branch
dividian they had bigger Firearms than
we had they were able to shoot through
doors due to that you know a lot of our
agents were
hurt 124 members survive in the comp
pound including David
[Music]
KES the FBI has called in to replace the
ATF I received a call from headquarters
and they said Bob pack a bag you need to
get ready and go down to Waco most
people were Shell Shocked it looked like
they were people who had just come back
from a combat zone we're still very much
concerned that he may Force his
followers to do things that are not
rational you don't walk away from an
incident where you have nine dead
bodies for the American people it's
another Grim episode of the ongoing
reality TV series called the
9s faced with stalled negotiations
federal agents are moving in more
Hardware people were tuning in every
night to see what was going to happen
how is this going to end it's like a
cliffhanger we had over 2,000 members of
the media present in fact it grew so
large that they established their own
Media city they elected a mayor of media
City we put up tents we put up uh
awnings uh one group of us spilled some
sand and put some plastic palm trees
down we had Margarita parties on Friday
nights probably more nights than just
that Bob RX and his team tried to
negotiate a peaceful settlement but Kesh
refuses to surrender claiming that he's
waiting for instructions from
God as the standoff turns from days into
weeks Spectators start to
arrive entrepreneurs capitalize on a bad
situation how much are the t-shirts hour
and why are you selling m a dollar to
some David Kesh and his followers become
Heroes Brave facing down a government
run a
muck I'm telling you you have to arm
yourself sometime against these type of
Gusto and kill them I'm not well hey
when they come in on your house you
going to let them come in on shoot you
what is happening over our city and in
this region and even across our nation
calls for God's people to stand up and
be
counted it's getting tense and tense and
tense and tense what's going to
happen the FBI cut all the power and
water to the compound forcing those
inside to survive on rainwater and
stockpiled Military rations meaning of
the Apocalypse is called the revelation
of Jesus Christ which God gave to him
the rhetoric of David carash is is
growing very dark he's making more
threatening uh comments there's a lot
more children than what they've said too
the real concern was how many would he
perhaps kill to cause an incident to
cause us to have to rush in so we would
be killed after 51 days of standoff and
worried by reports of child abuse inside
the compound the FBI decides to send in
the
tanks it appears as if they're starting
a full scale ranking operation almost I
guess in a sense to show they mean
business at this point yes they're
punching a hole in it you see it right
there see they've made a massive hole in
the side of that building
the fire
starts large large Flames now from the
top of the building uh this 40 mph wind
is is just whipping it uh Way Beyond
control the rest plays out live on
television huge huge clouds of black
smoke we don't see anybody coming out of
the compound
yet we literally could feel waves of he
from a mile
away coming across the field to where we
were from that
fire this is an area the size of a city
block that's on fire we are not seeing
any indication of Life
anywhere he was not coming out
peacefully it was always going to be on
his own
[Music]
terms
many blame the authorities for the
deaths and they fuel anti-government
paranoia this is the G Gordon litty
show the Bureau of Alcohol Tobacco and
Firearms comes to disarm you and they
are bearing arms resist them with arms
go for a head shot they're going to be
wearing bulletproof
vests there were more and more
right-wing extremist movements the
militia movement that were seizing on
that anti-government
feeling it's the the freedom of religion
freedom of speech freedom to bear
arms uh they weren't hurting anybody why
did the government have to go in there
and do what they
did the government continues to alienate
the people from it then war is
inevitable Revolution is
inevitable crazy is in the air and on
the airwaves they can't put 40 million
of you in jail but some crazy is
positively from a different
dimension for by the middle of the
decade real threats are being replaced
by existential and extraterrestrial
ones the Berlin Wall had fallen the Cold
War was over we were without a really
good villain uh we didn't quite know
what to be afraid of what do we have to
worry about next hey what about what's
way out in
space aliens feature unpopular talk
shows we're talking today with Harvard
University psychiatrist John Mack Mack
tells Oprah that he studied over 100
people who claim to have been abducted
by aliens they're taken up uh they may
see a spaceship they may not they may
see their home received there are
regular folk who tell you stories and
you say to yourself why would they lie
my mother and I have both had Close
Encounters of the Fourth Kind also known
as abduction experiences we've undergone
physical exam mination mind scan process
and reproductive processes Max study on
alien abduction gives Carter the idea
for a television show based on UFOs one
of the ways I pitched the X
Files was with Max scientific
survey I went in with I would call it
hard
science nobody ever lost money investing
in the paranoia of the American people
and the X Files becomes an incredible
hit the show that I created sort of
capitalized on a general sort of free
floating anxiety most of us here have
been taken many
times
taken taken where the bright white
place thing about the X Files it
reflected a very very deep suspicion on
the part of so many people in our
culture that who weren't being told the
truth xfiles Taps into this idea that
there are things out there that the
government knows of that the government
doesn't want us to know about
ufuf with the help of the internet the
culture of conspiracy spreads like some
kind of alien virus and in 1995 shocking
evidence of an alleged government
conspiracy
emerges when a documentary producer
claims to have gotten hold of mysterious
footage from an equally mysterious Army
cameraman in 1947 he' photographed what
was the crash of a vehicle he didn't
know whether it was a spaceship or a
flying sorcer but his job was to
photograph the recovery of the vehicle
and everything that occurred including
the
autopsies the tape reignites suspicion
of what really went down at Roswell Air
Force base New Mexico in
[Music]
the government is forced to respond the
Air Force issue two reports that claim
there were never any UFOs at
Roswell they had been dropping test
dummies into the desert the people there
saw body bags come out because the
dummies were put into body bags to
protect
them but the government denials didn't
stop people from believing the tape was
real why shouldn't they believe it it's
real except for a few tiny
things we reconstructed scenes the
person who helped create the creature is
special effects expert Focus or not it
was real enough to inspire an episode of
The X
Files what is it according to the
magazine ad I answered it's an alien
autopsy guaranteed authentic you spent
money for this
$29.95 plus shipping wild paranoia
against imagined enemies would come to
define the '90s but there were real
enemies out
there the Dark World of female figure
[Music]
skating only in the '90s could a figure
skating rivalry turn into a criminal
case a prime time soap opera and a
primal class struggle all at the same
time I've lived this whole
entire scenario for the last 20 years
and I will have to live it for the rest
of my
life us figure skater and Olympic
favorite Nancy carrian is leaving a
practice in Detroit but someone is
waiting in the
[Applause]
wings so
bad a man jumps out with a retractable
police baton and whacks her once on the
knee why
why
why why
indeed you know you can ask the question
why did it happen but I asked the
question why did it
[Music]
happened
scared the next day while Nancy is on
the sidelines her closest rival Tanya
Harding wins at the Nationals
guaranteeing her a spot on the Olympic
team Harding is a fierce competitor to
some too
Fierce I'm really happy but it won't be
a true Crown until I get my chance of NY
and that'll be Olympics and let me tell
you I'm in a whipper
butt but then shocking news
breaks wake up and the lead story is the
FBI is investigating Tanya Harding's
husband in the attack on Nancy
car oh my
God the story grips the nation and just
3 weeks after the attack her ex-husband
Jeff galui pleads guilty but accuses
Tanya of being The Mastermind Tanya
categorically denies those allegations
you know I haven't done anything wrong
Jeff and his buddies thought that they
were going to start up a security
business I mean morons that couldn't
even polish shoes or put one foot in
front of the other one I thought what
they did was you
know some very very
hood you know what I'm saying if I had
big money they would be able to use my
money to make their money I mean
everybody in my life has always used me
you guys will you go away please with an
entire nation watching on TV Tanya
maintains she didn't plan the attack is
not
true anybody who knows me knows it's not
true she was able to figure out how to
play her hand how to get those violin
strings
rolling it was quite
remarkable people have to open their
ears have an open mind and get all the
facts before you start pointing
fingers after weeks of denial Tanya
finally admits she did know about the
attack but only when her ex-husband
privately confessed after the event she
maintains that he physically threatened
her in order to stop her from telling
anyone else I am embarrassed and ashamed
as she has not yet been found guilty of
any crime Tanya is still allowed to face
a now recovered Nancy carrian at the
Olympics just keep believing in me and
I'm going to go there and I'm going to
win I want what I want tell me
[Music]
what assigned to cover the T beat
24/7 is veteran CBS reporter Connie Chun
Nancy carrian was the pure white lily
princess Tanya Hardin was the bad girl
the wicked witch But ultimately we
reporters both print and television
enhanced
those roles
every single person out there that's in
media wanted a piece of me I couldn't
even
breathe and I get hit in the head all
the time with the
cameras and that hurts forget Nancy and
Tanya the real battle here was between
Tanya and
Connie the world is not talking about
you because of your figure skating you
know that don't
you m no no I mean I have to hand it to
her she was wickedly wild Wy she was
wickedly Wy it has to do with the
controversy it has to do with the attack
it has to do with skating she just kept
asking the same question like two three
different times actually I think it was
like three or four times and I kept
telling her the same answer I'm not
going to talk about that because I don't
know how any other way of answering the
questions that you ask me so if you
don't like it I'm not going to answer
that tough what you knew about the
attack after okay I'm done I'm done with
this thanks Connie would I take it
personally oh
please God she's gone thank the Lord
thank
you Nancy carrian was asked her odds
given all the controversy it's kind of
like reading a book and you just can't
wait to get to the end and see what
happens just so proud to be a part of
America his cheering section for all of
you when Nancy and Tanya competed is the
sixth highest rated show in US
television history forever
[Music]
more Nancy caring was just terrific took
the lead in the competition and was was
poised for a gold
medal but then in the second routine
disaster Tanya need to change her
lace suddenly she goes crying to the
judges puts her
skate my my laces are
broken lordy in this group get out of
the way get out we'll do the whole
thing hello people this is not
hockey Tanya completes her final routine
but scores poorly and finishes eight
but Nancy carrian wins the silver
[Music]
[Applause]
medal you know what I'm human I have
feelings I had a life at least I thought
I did Tanya Harding was a tabloid
princess who many thought belonged on a
different kind of TV show than that
stuffy live Olympics and every one knew
just what that show
was it has to be outrageous
inappropriate outside the norm of
accepted Behavior because that's what
the show is about I don't know why that
sort of real life despair destruction
freak Show you know dysfunction
intrigues us so much but it does we're
fascinated by
it nine years ago I spent time with a
woman I shouldn't have and I paid a with
a check I wish I hadn't done that and
the truth is I wish no one would ever
know but in the rough world of politics
opponents are not about to let personal
embarrassments lay to rest my background
is politics when I couldn't run again
NBC came to me and said you've just
finished your terms as mayor and we'd
like you to Anchor the news this is News
5 at 6 with G Springer we were pretty
dominant in the rating so one day they
take me to lunch and said we're starting
a new T show you're going to host it two
stor when the jur your show started it
was actually a kind of respectable show
he had legitimate political figures he
had Jesse Jackson on he had Oliver North
on come season two the ratings are
completely tanking Mr
J with the show about to be cancelled a
new producer gives it a very Extreme
Makeover I came up with make the show
interesting with the sound off there
would be something on that screen that
would make you
stop
the Jerry Jerry Jerry chant came because
if the audience was on their feet
chanting Jerry Jerry people were going
to think he was famous we decided we're
only going to have young people in the
audience and young subject matter well
young people are much more open about
their lives much crazier Wilder and so
the show started to go crazy I'm really
a
man it has to be outrageous in
appropriate outside the norm of accepted
Behavior because that's what the show
was about it's just the greatest thing
there is the show didn't need to fight
for a viewing audience the viewing
audience starts to fight for the
[Music]
[Applause]
show nothing succeeds like excess and
the brawls become a
ritual here I am a Chicago police
officer and not even trying to be an
entertainment field and when the show
took off it was
huge it's hilarious it's Billy's
fighting you
know he's actually been sleeping with
her best friend to Springer the show
tapped into a universal truth you take
an English Professor from
Harvard if he comes home one night and
finds his wife in bed with a nextdoor
neighbor do you for one second think
that that very well cultured educated
English Professor would say for sooth my
dear what is it that I have
found no he'd say get out of here he'd
start throwing things screaming yelling
the truth is in a certain situation we
all behave the same way please welcome
Alexa to the
show I can't believe that I have an
outfit just like
it I know that you know that I've been
with man and things but oh
God in the chase for ratings the show
becomes a petri dish of aberant social
behaviors here is your brother he goes
by the name now of
Hillary everything is up for grabs every
individual personal relationship is now
potentially a subject of entertainment
for the
public we don't need to spend money on
National Defense anymore because when
other countries see our show no one
wants to come over and take us over
anymore
he's better than
Oprah if you want to save the whales
call Oprah if you're sleeping with the
whale call
us Jerry Springer might have been the
beginning of the end of really great
television for a while because there was
we have really great television now but
there was a period where it became
really crap but crap is in the eye of
the beholder ratings are soaring and
imitation being the sincerest form of
Television the Springer circus inspires
a host of copycats Look Who's Talking
Now 14 new talk shows will try to be
heard along with 19 existing blab fests
by fall of
1995 TV is no longer low brow it's no
[Applause]
brow and this race to the bottom leads
to a deadly
stumble a guest on the Jenny Jones Show
is invited to meet a secret admirer and
discovers on air that his admirer is
another man he's got a cute little hard
[Music]
body Jonathan Schmidt is so humiliated
he shoots his secret
admirer at that point people sort of had
to stop and take a a hard look at okay
what are we considering to be
entertainment we will have no censorship
this is free fre speech this is America
the Jenny Jones Show brought a fragile
character subjected him to humiliation
and look what they produced they had a
powder
[Music]
cake get but it seems there's no going
back and by 1998 the mayor of
dysfunction Junction is beating Oprah in
the ratings Jerry's invited to speak at
Oxford University and other even more
prestigious honors father
it's
[Applause]
okay Mike Myers said let's destroy the
set and we destroyed the set just
throwing chairs and breaking the walls
down it was it was crazy and it was
really cool now an icon Springer is
honored by the cultural Elite becoming
the subject of an opera so just to recap
no heing no fighting no no throwing
things or throwing up throwing up my mom
would have been been proud when I became
an opera you know she said Gerald you
got some culture you're an
opera despite entering an economic boom
the last great superpower America is
tearing itself apart at
home closing
time open all the doors and let you out
into
why and it's about to face a new kind of
war
overseas in a country many Americans
have never heard of when those Marines
hit the beaches in Somalia expecting
perhaps to be attacked they were met by
c
Cruz America has gone to Somalia to
distribute famine relief don't home you
within a few weeks the problem we went
to solve was fixed food was flowing the
people were being taken care of then I
think a strategic Choice was made which
was not perhaps the the best one that
was okay now that we're here in order to
keep this from happening again let's
establish a democratic system somalia's
Capital Mogadishu is run by heavily
armed militias driving Mad Max style war
machines US troops were tasked with
taking down powerful Somali warlord
Muhammad
[Music]
idid Sunday afternoon October 3rd we
launched a mission to take down two high
ranking leaders in ID's clan that were
meeting at the same time Army Rangers
from my unit flew in on Blackhawk
helicopters my role was to lead the long
column of Humvees through the city
streets to position close to the Target
building the world's leading super power
versus a bunch of guys in pickup
trucks what could possibly go
wrong we were already getting sporadic
enemy gunfire as soon as I pulled
up we had six Blackhawks hovering over
the
target the entire city seemed like it
was shooting
at and they have the right tools for the
job thousands of RPGs were fired into
the sky that
day it's basically fly your helicopters
through a wall of Rocket propell
grenades and eventually you're going to
get
[Music]
hit this is not the kind of Hollywood
ending America had
anticipated I think that was the moment
that all of us realized none of us may
make it out of the city
alot how did a humanitarian Mission turn
violent Jeff strucker's mission to
arrest ad's deputies now becomes a
desperate attempt to rescue their own
injured
comrades now they've got a very
significant force in danger vastly
outnumbered by a very well-armed
citizenry out in the streets of
Mogadishu we were getting shot at from a
100 directions we were trying to return
fire to rooftops and Alleyways and
doorways and windows all at the same
time down the road on the right side
waiting for us was a Somali gun and when
we got right next to him he saw one of
the machine Gunners named Dominic pillow
at the same time that pillow saw him
these two guys turned their weapons to
each other at the same
moment pillow was shot in the forehead
and he was killed
instantly after taking his dead and
injured colleagues back to the base Jeff
then returns to Mogadishu to try and
rescue the helicopter crew he gets
within a few hundred meters of the down
Chopper but there's no way
through the next time he sees his
comrades is on
TV a dozen US soldiers are dead scores
wounded and at least one is a captive
tonight in the hellhole that is
soma so we were getting the live news
broadcast like everybody else in the
world we were watching our friends
corpses being mutilated on television
for the whole world to
see and it made all of of us so
angry a nation who reveled in the images
of Desert Storm is reminded that war is
indeed
hell despite all the casualties Pentagon
officials say they succeeded in
capturing 19 of ad's followers but if
this operation was a success then the US
can't stand much more success than
Somalia do what we have to do and get
out we may never win it's kind of like
Vietnam Blackhawk Down essentially made
everybody take a look and say uh okay
look we need to disengage from this the
president's orders to me were we're
going to stay there for 6 months during
those 6 months I do not want another
American Soldier to die and that meant
not engaging With the
Enemy I'm absolutely convinced that may
have been one of the worst foreign
policy decisions in the US history I
mean essentially what the US government
was saying to the world is if you punch
Us in the nose hard enough if you you
make us bleed we'll put our tail between
our legs and we'll run
away one man in particular was watching
very
closely bin Len his big takeaway from
all this is if you inflict enough damage
on the United States it's just going to
pull out of wherever you want it to pull
out of Clinton pulls back from acting as
the world's
policeman 6 months later in Rwanda an
estimated 800,000 people die at this
time the United States would not
intervene America is looking Inward and
some people don't like what they
see
fortunately there's a pill for that
people aren't really talking about I
just took seven Viking and how many how
many did you take it's mostly about
hiding
it the San Diego Padres are about to
take on the Cincinnati Reds in a
mid-season
game little did America
know the terror was about to hit a home
[Applause]
[Music]
run another tragedy a national
tragedy my reaction is it was
disgraceful I started too high it all
depends on just how you define
High despite being at the peak of her
success Rosanne bar was on a combination
of psychiatric drugs at the
time prescription meds were just a
fantastic uh way to cope I mean when you
want to sleep you'll sleep especially if
you're working and uh you know if you're
really depressed and you have to produce
you kind of thought well you know Better
Living Through
chemicals
Rosanne was tapping into this new
reality of America as the early 1990s
saw the introduction of a brand new type
of anti-depressants known as
ssris Chief among them
Prozac talk to your doctor today or
visit
prozac. welcome back thanks to Prozac
it's now not only okay to admit
depression it's actually
encouraged everybody was like well
bipolar ranic depressor you I mean it
was like all these the Advent of these
new you know psychological drugs on
Prozac for a long
time America and its medication is
literally going to the dogs and it was
like a miracle cure for Jake he gets his
proac and it eases him right through his
his anxious moments and they're just no
out there that there were plenty of
doctors going around that were willing
to just
write a script all day long and give
these kids whatever they wanted look my
stomach really hurts all I can give you
are these chewable Prozac for kids your
choice manic depressive mouse or the
bluebird of
unhappiness but America's love of
prescription drugs is not confined to
anti-depressants I wouldn't know
anything about prescription drug use
problems but uh I can guess at some of
them following a jet ski accident
Matthew Perry becomes addicted to
vicadin a prescription
painkiller I was in the throws of a
problem and I didn't talk to anybody
about it it's very secret people aren't
really talking about you know I just
took seven vikin and how many how many
did you take it's mostly about hiding it
the line between street drugs and
prescription medicine is becoming
blurred the euphoric high was the same
even though you were you know paying
money at a pharmacy and getting a
legitimate
[Music]
prescription in 1997 Matthew Perry
checks himself into rehab Roseanne Bar
also gets off the meds but she's never
invited to sing the national anthem
[Music]
again while some entertainers are
looking to escape reality others find a
way to turn their reality into Platinum
even if they me they can never take the
life of
a there is absolutely no reason for a
record like this to be published by a
responsible
[Music]
Corporation Tupac wanted to rock the
establishment from its
foundation he's a brilliant artist he
was a brilliant artist he still is it
even even when he's not with
us I would never think that the West
Coast Beef East Coast beef ever would
get to a stage where you know people
wanted to kill each
other the short life and mysterious
death of Tupac Shakur is the archetypal
9s story celebrity violence and even
conspiracy that all comes together on
the night of September 7th
1996 boxing sensation Mike Tyson is
about to
fight among the celebrity attende is the
prince of rap Tupac
Shakur when the opening bell rings Tyson
goes on the
attack it's dramatic it's edgy and then
it's
over 60 seconds boom that's how great
Tyson was it was so quick everybody was
like damn it's over already then the
fighting spills out of the
ring it was really
scary cuz fights were breaking out and
Tupac and his record producer sug Knight
get into a fight a surveillance camera
captures the
action sugar Pock was stomping this
guy guess he was a
violence is a vital component of
Tupac Shakur's
[Music]
work
but kids love to love music that their
parents hate was a little like what the
heck are you singing are you kidding
me white kids in Suburbia u USA are like
huge Tupac fans and want to wear the
bandana and get
tattooed that's like they worst
nightmare we were rolling down the 405
just listening to Tac and we thought
that we
badasses rappers say it's not the music
causing the
violence it's the violence that's
music listen there's violence in the
star spangle Banner you know so you know
there's always going to be talk about
guns and bursting and Blasting and this
and that just because that's just the
nature of the fabric of
America but authenticity can go too far
and Tupac gets caught between two sides
of a gang war the West Coast said forget
you we're the future you're the past and
it became once they were friends now
East Coast rapper Biggie Smalls becomes
Tupac's biggest
enemy all these suckers they battling
off of East and West like this is a game
this ain't no game if this was chess
we'd be yelling Checkmate three years
ago cuz we've been beat these and some
believe it's Biggie's crew who are out
to get Tupac after the Tyson fight
after leaving the arena the rival gangs
disperse we were going to perform do a
show big party everybody was going to be
there the atmosphere in the club 6es 2
was very funky it just seemed like there
were a lot of you know questionable
characters in there Tupac is in route to
the club what happens next is still
shrouded in
mystery we're caravaning it's maybe 20
cars I had a feeling something bad was
going to
happen everything seemed like to move in
in in slow
motion I wanted to get a look at the
faces of the people of the hand I was
holding the gun I just remember saying
damn I wish I could see his face in the
hospital Tupac fights for his life me
and the Outlaws and we all took shifts
and you know the Outlaws I think they
had weapons in the car because the whole
time we were there we were fearful
they're going to come finish him off
after 6 days Tupac Shakur dies from
multiple gunshot
injuries Tupac's gang The Outlaws claim
they smoke his
ashes Pac told us mystery selles so I'll
let people wonder and the biggest
mystery is who's behind the murder of
Tupac Shakur Tupac did shoot two
off-duty police officers down in Atlanta
so law enforcement around the country
weren't big Tupac fans did the police
conceal The
Killers I'm absolutely positive they
know what happened this is America you
know what I mean we found Bin Laden I
believe that if Justin Bieber had gotten
shot in Tupac's car we'd know more the
police say their investigation stalled
not for lack of
effort but because Witnesses refused to
cooperate
Tupac's unique Persona lives on fueling
conspiracy theories that his murder was
a hoax
[Applause]
what but America was about to find out
just how deadly a real conspiracy could
be we all remember where we were when we
saw
it I bought my first grownup te set in
1995 and it arrived and the delivery guy
put it in and we turned it
on a massive Car Bomb exploded outside
of a large Federal Building in downtown
Oklahoma City the first thing that came
on was the Oklahoma City bombing about a
third of the building has been blown
away it was like seeing 9911 or
something and like you couldn't believe
it was happening even though it was
happening in front of my face for those
inside the building it's a harrowing
experience I remember this brilliant
flash of light my whole desk in the area
around me just lit up great
Flash and then there was this tremendous
noise
defening all of a
sudden it stopped just like
that then I started hearing Cries From
the people around me so I went over and
dug both of them
out the exit door had been blown open so
I knew that if I took them back there I
could get him
out I went back in it was pitch dark I
mean you couldn't see anything toward
the
front I didn't have a choice what to do
I'm there among all these people who
needed who were crying for
help
[Music]
we're trying to get people to the
hospitals as quickly as we can at the
same time we now have a crime scene that
we're trying to
protect at first many believe this
bombing is an Arab terrorist attack a
strike against the World Trade Center 2
years previously but then the date
begins to take on an ominous
significance my assistant agent in
charge says Bob you know what today is
and I said ' whatat do you mean he says
today is April
19th April 19th is the anniversary of
the final assault on
Waco the previous year the one-year
anniversary of Waco we had been on high
alert throughout the whole country
nothing happened the Alfred E mura
Federal Building housed government
offices including the local Bureau of
the
ATF like the World Trade Center bombers
in
1993 the Oklahoma bomber leaves evidence
behind and Timothy McVey is arrested
within two
days I can't I can't comprehend his what
he was thinking in his mind when he did
that it was it's beyond comprehension I
was shocked that a fellow American would
do this to
Americans what was more shocking to
Michelle was that she had met McVey
before at wakeo Tim McBay was sitting on
the hood of his car very unassuming
camouflage ball cap looking all
American he was there
to express a fear for the government I
just arrived
today I guess somebody told me a lot of
people are would be scared to put
something on
there he was fearful of big government
he was fearful of the government that in
his opinion wanted wanted to control the
everyday lives of
Americans as the country tries to come
to terms with this tragedy the mourner
and chief flies to Oklahoma
City this was not universally thought to
be a good idea Bill Clinton was
struggling in the wake of an election
campaign where Democrats lost the house
and the Senate um and it was very
tumultuous
winter on April 18th just one day before
the Oklahoma bombing the president
looked vulnerable yes Jud Republicans
have dominated political debate in this
country since they took over Congress in
January and even tonight two of the
major television networks declined to
broadcast this event live do you worry
about making sure that your voice is
heard in the coming months no the
president is relevant here he needed to
assert himself he wanted to make sure
that he hadn't disappeared off the face
of
Washington the tragedy of April 19th
gives Clinton his chance to reach out
you have lost too
much but you have not lost
everything and you have certainly not
lost America I found him to be very very
sincere he was talking to as one of us
if anybody thinks that Americans are
mostly mean and selfish they ought to
come to
Oklahoma it would be hard to find any
presidential speech in the last half of
the 20th century or end of the 21st
century that was better attuned to the
moment Clinton's speech temporarily
restores faith in his presidency but the
war is far from
over Republicans have a very Lethal
Weapon at their
disposal an excellent role model for the
Youth of America or anybody else needing
guidance for that matter I am Rush lmau
Rush has an incredible peal in taking
complex political and social issues
synthesizing them in a way people
understand if there was ever a program
that inspires independent thought uh it
is this one Rush would be able to say no
no this is all baloney here's how you
ought to think the views expressed by
the hosts on the show will soon become
federal
law right never ever underestimate a man
who overestimates himself you know what
all caused
this me he had about 23 million
listeners well that's every 10th
American so when he said something you
were getting messages across to a large
part of the country Rush Limba is
personally credited with helping
Republicans win those 1994 midterm
elections that was the moment that the
Republican Party began to rely on on
talk show hosts to make its case for
them and it's partly thanks to rush why
n Gingrich is King of the Hill there was
a brief period when the president was
clearly on defense clearly didn't quite
know what he was doing how is it that
the Democrats keep approaching people as
though they're stupid Clinton never won
the majority of the popular vote there
were a lot of people who were convinced
he wasn't really the president the
Republicans strike while their iron is
hot setting a trap for Clinton
the core issue is that for 60 years we
have been borrowing our children's money
we now owe $5
trillion they propose severe budget cuts
everybody believed Clinton was weak
everybody believed they could push him
around it's a win-win maneuver if
Clinton opposes gingrich's budget he's a
defender of big deficits if he gives in
the Republicans take
control I grabbed him by his shoulders
and I shook him you know he he huge I'm
short the tow over me and I shook him
and I said where is your nerve you used
to win votes by taking aggressive
forward positions now you're scared of
your own damn Shadow what's gotten into
you Dick Morris has a plan we will
balance the budget and we will cut
spending but we're only going to cut it
in certain areas not in the core areas
the Republicans will not accept
compromise it's their way or the
shutdown my way the choice will be his
the government shuts down his
fingerprints are going to be all over
November 14th 1995 the federal
government runs out of
money the Washington passport agency is
closed for lack of fund due to the
shutdown of the federal government the
National Park Service is closed
indefinitely they don't shut down the
helium Reserve or the give cell phones
to the homeless program or millions of
other pointless and wasteful Federal
programs they shut down Yellowstone why
because it infuriates everyone with a
camper van we're shutting her down till
further notice okay while millions of
unhappy campers are denied their fun one
very happy camper has a different idea
in mind anybody home yes somebody was
home the full-time staff had to be
furloughed and therefore the typing and
the filing was done by
inur it was a bit like the kids taking
over the store the interns were given
responsibilities which they normally
didn't have and were interacting with
the VIPs of politics in a way which was
not
normal Monica Lewinsky isn't the only
major political risk Clinton is taking
the shutdown will either make him or
break him it felt very much like a
personal fight between Clinton and
Gingrich in the most visceral of terms
it was who blinks first it wasn't really
about policy it was about the tribalism
that had taken over America American
politics the red versus blue tribalism
Clinton just said I'm just I'm just not
going to sign a bill that cuts Medicare
and forces me to do these things I'm not
nobody really knew how that was going to
end wake up you bunch of dummies and get
with it there very much was a bunker
mentality the poll numbers showed
tremendous support for him so he stayed
perfectly firm he never blinked Clinton
is doing the right thing as far as the
people are concerned he saw correctly
the shutdown as a lifeline it was a judo
move you fall backward but you take your
opponent head over heels with you so he
understood the Republicans will be
blamed after 27 days of shutdown Bill
Clinton triumphs the Republicans give in
he said to me at one point you know I'm
like that clown that had sand in the
bottom and you'd hit it and it would go
over but it would always come back up he
said I'm not not pretty but I always
come back up he emerges as a stronger
president but has to change the way he
governs the era of big government is
over but we can't go back to the era of
fending for yourself then Clinton rubs
it in they were looking for someone that
was a rescuer and someone who had been
locked out of their office during the
furlows he uses the hero of the Oklahoma
bombing to cement his victory on behalf
of Richard Dean and his family I
challenge all of you in this chamber
never ever shut the federal government
down
again the first thing popped in my mind
was we got a little bit of gamesmanship
going on here well at least the
government will never shut down again oh
wait well Bill Clinton was clearly a
greater politician than he was
profit but profit he does from this 1995
shutdown although though his popularity
sores never underestimate Bill Clinton's
pronatural ability to get back into
trouble in the '90s there's still a worm
eating deep inside the Big
Apple the mafia this was a particular
problem for New York that had five mafia
families most other cities had only one
New York had five and of all of the
Mafia bosses none is bigger than the
head of the Gambino family John Gotti he
was media darling it's giv $50 bills to
homeless
[Music]
people we all love the bad guy it's the
way it is there's some kind of romance
about the mafia three times the
government has tried to convict Gotti
not guilty three times it has
failed is John G a Mafia Boss no no
absolutely not that's right absolutely
absolutely not absolutely without a
doubt you're say you're saying this
honestly cross your heart and hope to
die
absolutely B all that changes when the
FBI bugs Gambino headquarters
you Gotti's right-hand man breaks the
Code of
Silence triggering the downfall of the G
Empire my father is the last of the
meagans and the mob in cities across
America
America and then the floodgates open
maid guys captains under bosses celier
later on bosses themselves
flipped organized crime may be choked
but disorganized crime still has a
strangle hold over New York it's so
prevalent it's even parody by some of
America's favorite fantasy New Yorkers
pretend that I'm robbing you
huh why so these people can go back home
and tell their friends they saw real New
York muggy give them a thrill all right
hand up poor
key you got but this is no laughing
matter in just the first 6 months of
this year 35 of our City's children have
been shot and killed in 91 and '92 we
were about 2,200 murders a year it's
like a war zone officials admit they are
outnumbered and outgunned New York was a
giant pulsing dysfunction you were never
going to get on top
doctors in our hospitals used to tell me
this was like what they experienced in
Vietnam against a backdrop of
unrelenting violence New York decides it
needs a new sheriff in town there's just
no way New York City ever votes for a
republican unless it's desperate and
they were
desperate Rudy Giuliani is elected
mayor the simple fact is we have to try
to fight back we just can't sit here and
let this kind of Carnage go on Giuliani
and his new police chief Bill Brad
Implement a zero tolerance crime
initiative lock them up it's the only
way we're going to stop it we can reduce
crime we can deal with quality of life
effectively we can reduce fear and we
can change Behavior you need to pay
attention to the little things because
if you don't they can become big things
and the results are almost
immediate cover saying it's the end of
crime is we know it which people said
you're crazy this is just a a one-year
blip well as it turns out it was the
beginning of this ongoing 20year
reduction in violent
[Music]
crime all of this progress has had a
rather Sinister side effect New York is
becoming
nice meet America's other favorite
fantasy New
Yorkers certainly was the opposite of
gritty sign photos in the New York
before Giuliani fixed it uh and friends
is in the New York after we got a
tremendous amount of flak over the
apartments and how big they were and
could these people really afford and I
would always say they're much cheaper
because there's no fourth wall so if
your apartment didn't have a fourth wall
and you lost all
anonymity it it would be affordable
friends was based on reality well sort
of the six characters on friends aren't
literally based on us or
I mean yeah colors I mean I would say
there's an element of Ross a kind of
neurotic um and also chanler absolutely
hey that monkey's got a Ross on his
ass friends was also fueled by the
experiences of its actors with no detail
too small to be
ignored in real life I'm missing the end
of my finger and I think they wanted to
do something about that and I said let
that be my thing personally and so they
just changed it to a toe what we got
here 20-year-old male he's got a sever
toe on his right
foot yeah it was funny you brought a
carrot what this isn't your toe this is
a small very cold piece of
carrot in the mid99s friends are hanging
out in a Sophisticated New York brimming
with coffee shops would anybody like
more
coffee did you make it or are you just
serving it I'm just serving it yeah I'll
have a cup of
coffee suddenly in the '90s you're
looking around and like wow they're
getting coffee and they're sitting on
sofas we saw a place like that and we
were like huh that looks
[Music]
nice friends hugging it out introduces a
new kind of family onto our TV screens
where is she think conceit of the show
was that your friends were your family
and in a lot of cases that was certainly
true in the '90s I remember when I first
came to this city I was 14 my mom had
just killed herself and my stepdad was
back in prison and I got here and I
didn't know anybody they wanted to show
that it was okay that people had flaws
and you didn't have to show the American
Family nuclear as Perfection the
circumstances of Matt Perry's childhood
are reflected in the
series
I'm not a big holiday guy like sort of
forced fun forced jolliness oh oh I'm a
duck I go quack quack I'm happy all the
time and that actually echoed in the
character that he only had grilled
cheese sandwiches and he had bad
memories of Thanksgiving in the past now
Chandler dear just because your father
and I are getting a divorce doesn't mean
we don't love you it just means he would
rather sleep with the house boy than
with me in the TV series Chandler's dad
is a
transsexual played by Kathleen Turner
what an unusual name you must have had
terribly fascinating parents oh they're
a
hoot there is one father figure of an
entire dysfunctional
nation and now God's gift to radio the
very horny Mr Howard Stern Stern's radio
show has 16 million listeners there's
nobody going to jail for marijuana right
now and as far as I'm concerned I don't
care what anybody does let them smoke
their brains out till they freaking die
there's too many people on the planet
his libertarian views spawn
books
movie and mass
adoration Howard Stern is just a guy
who's really a Carnival Barker with a
with a radio platform some Carnival
some platform I am the most honest
person in the world today believe me
anybody who admits having a 1-in penis
is honest well I think Howard like takes
the the veils off you know people he
takes the veils off of men and their
grass disgusting behavior and people
like get a kick out of it it's fun it's
crazy it's the way men are I got a mind
just like him dirty funny and clever
remember that tenuous line between
politics and entertainment in the 9s
with Stern that line is way out of line
and the Stern Show even sends its own
correspondents to crash press
conferences the governor Clinton use a
condom Jes right here was there ever a
threesome will you be sleeping with any
other presidential
[Music]
candidates in his own loudmouth way
Stern is a kind of
revolutionary even staging a gay dance
party live on the air
have you ever danced with a man before
is that what they call these days
dancing was that really John
Stewart in the 9s walls come down that
are not located in
[Music]
Berlin homosexuality is no longer a
completely taboo subject in
[Music]
America remember this
cover I thought wow that's really cheeky
and you Katie Lang this is somebody who
in an era where it wasn't really that
cool to have that kind of Courage he
just said lay it on baby this is me that
Cindy Crawford Katie Lang moment was the
Pinnacle of it it was sheer lesbian
Insanity another cultural revolutionary
gets in on the action it's too soon it's
too soon come
on big baby
all right her name is Mara I'm seeing a
woman it was a very important step for
me to get gay characters on television
she said oh would you play a gay
character I said yeah I think that would
be fun it would be funny and crazy I
have a gay brother and a gay
[Music]
sister and soon other gay figures are
emboldened to come out of the closet I
felt that if I wanted to be truthful
then I had to be truthful all the
way guest stars and rock stars are one
thing America's sitcom sweetheart to
something
else in the 9s Ellen degenerous was
intensely private about her personal
life where are
you I was in the
closet but on the night of April 30th
1997 that would change I'm so afraid to
tell people I mean I just
Susan I'm
gay it was enormous Roseanne had earlier
done a gay storyline but that was that
was fiction we all knew it was fiction
Ellen's coming out on National
Television is a watershed
moment she must have fact this huge
relief come on that felt so great and it
felt so
loud it helps the girl turn to her
parents and go yeah well I'm gay too it
helps the the young boy go yeah I'm gay
too and it makes it not as
bad but while being gay has started to
become more acceptable in mainstream
media in Wyoming things are not quite so
open the sky that goes forever it's it's
beautiful in its own unique way
um but it's kind of challenging to be
there politically Judy Shepard has a son
named Matthew who is different from the
other boys in his
class I actually began to wonder when
Matt was about eight if he was gay and
uh one of the clues might have been
might have been that for 3 years in a
row he dressed up like Dolly Parton when
Matthew is in college he comes to a
realization he called me in the middle
of the night and said Mom I'm I'm gay
and I said Matt what took you so long to
tell me and there's this sort of quiet
at the other end of the phone and he
said how did you know before I knew the
shepherd family embraced their son's
sexuality but others
don't two people passing this fence on
Wednesday thought they were looking at a
scarecrow when they looked closer they
realized it was the savagely beaten body
of a young man who had been tied to the
fence and left to die in the cold got a
call in the middle of the night about
5:00 in the morning I guess and um
it was the hospital calling us and said
your son has been injured it's a crime
that will transform America two young
men have been arrested and charged with
attempted first-degree murder Shepherd's
attackers are accused of torturing him
and according to the affidavit filed in
court attempting to kill their victim by
beating him with the butt of a pistol he
never regained
Consciousness after 6 days with his
family beside him Matthew succumbs to
his injury
it was sort of a wakeup call to reality
we in the entertainment business and and
in media in general had been riding this
beautiful wave of gay is
okay just putting him on the fence the
way they left the body and the cruelty
and the bullying those sorts of things
you don't ever
forget Matthew's Funeral becomes a media
circus this is the most absurd thing any
anyone could ever imagine having to
print tickets and write out names
invitations basically for a funeral of
their child who does
that and it's not only supporters of
Matthew Shepard who attend United States
government and the United Nations cannot
protect you from a holy God we knew they
were going to come the police department
had set up a SWAT team around the church
we were out and talking to the Press
Dennis was wearing a bulletproof
vest how stupid is that right that's
great
his family and friends went more than
ever to say their farewells to him in a
peaceful dignified and loving manner we
knew Matt would become the quote unquote
poster child of the movement we kind of
encouraged it because we thought as long
as they're talking about Matt story and
they're talking about Dennis and I we
can be accepting parents who set an
example for parents who reject their
kids this is what we want Matthews
killers are sentenced to spend the rest
of their lives behind bars but it will
take 11 more years for Congress to pass
a long awaited Bill Federal protections
against crimes based on gender
disability gender identity or sexual
orientation it will become known as the
Matthew Shepard act that one story
changed more Hearts you can call it the
Tipping Point we have made progress I
think Matt would be pleased all we
wanted to do is try and make it
better it struck without warning
first the infection was local confined
only to Miami Beach I remember being in
a club looking down and saying why is
everybody country line dancing to a
Spanish
s there's potential for Mass contagion a
radio station down in Miami was dying to
play the song but they were an all-
English station but first the virus
needs to be deliberately
weaponized so they came to us and said
guys can you do something with this song
so we can play
it hidden in a laboratory in Florida men
with no sense of shame or Mercy
finalized the
[Music]
assembly this was a 2-hour project this
was do a rudimentary mix send it to the
radio station it was as simple as that
chaos soon descend upon a helpless
population
[Music]
amarina oh I forgot that
one the central governing authorities of
the Earth are themselves consumed I
would like to demonstrate for
you the Al Gore version of the Macarena
well that's proof of the pudding you
know everybody was dancing the Macarena
even Al Gore who
has would you like to see it
again the military stands helpless for
this weapon of mass
distraction well I was at a Boys and
Girls Club in Arizona and one young girl
said can you dance the macarina and so I
said to her sure I
can and next thing I knew I was in
National Television dancing the Macar oh
my God I have to be
careful I think everyone who attempted
the Macarena is probably lucky that the
videotape from that era is terribly
grainy on
[Music]
playback the infection finally
subsides but soon some recovered victims
come to realize that the experience has
actually changed them for the
better as macarina busts the door down
for Latin artists crossing over into the
American Market a lot of people came out
of the Shadows JLo Ricky Martin it
brought a whole new flavor to the
American pop scene by the late 1990s the
Latino population is set to surpass
African-Americans between the Latino
Hispanic community and the
African-American community and the Asian
community in one more generation say
another 20 years they will represent the
majority of Americans over
50% everyone in America did share one
thing in the 9s and that was complete
confusion as to what the internet really
was and where to go once we got
[Music]
there when we need a fact it's like we
get it in seconds so it's it's hard to
go back and think about in the 1990s
when we didn't have those search engines
like what did we do when Tim burner's
Lee invented the web in
1991 he put in the structure that we
have today websites and names but he
didn't occur to him to have a way of
searching them cuz they weren't that
many the on-ramp was there America
Online can do all that but the
information Super Highway has way too
many detours and dead ends everyone says
that you can just search the web and all
of a sudden happen upon stuff but I
can't I can't find anything on
it but some see a road map to the Future
Stanford University students Larry pagee
and Sergey Brin are t-shirt wearing
Burning Man loving cultural Renegades
but they also have a magic
formula one that will better organize
search what Google did was it found a a
way to use other people that was called
page rank the more popular the page the
higher up on the search list simple
right it was a different way of
determining what order to present those
billion results
[Music]
in and Google's original storage rack is
made from Legos these guys were playful
but it played to their advantage why did
the 40-some not do it CU we were all of
us were hobbled by convention and they
saw A New
Path when I initially interviewed with
Gogle I remember seeing Larry come out
of the elevator on one of those little
hopping balls with handles on it this
guy goes right on by me okay that's
interesting so I left the interview
thinking to myself these guys are crazy
this former Chef for the Grateful Dead
is not put off they told me cook
whatever you want cook from your heart
cook what you believe we should be
eating Larry and Sergey figure free food
along with bouncing balls will keep
their employees happy and working hard
that and some worthless stock options I
called my dad I like pop I need to
borrow a little bit of money to buy
these stock options he was very
skeptical Charlie's dad wasn't the only
skeptic but soon that would
change my dad now like worships Google
as his second
God
a Manhunt is underway in Los Angeles at
this hour for OJ
Simpson we're over the five freeway OJ
Simpson is believed to be in the white
Bronco followed by as many as Nine
Orange County sheriff's
deputies it began for days
earlier the body of 34-year-old Nicole
Brown Simpson ex-wife of OJ Simpson was
found after midnight on the sidewalk
walk outside her West Los Angeles home
next to it the body of an unidentified
26-year-old Man by the '90s if anyone
gave OJ Simpson and he thought it would
be as a sports icon or an affable golfer
oh jeez that was about as bad as it gets
ever need to rent a car
fast star of TV
commercials and so bad he was almost
good
actor but nobody I mean nobody could
conceive that this Sports icon could be
charged with a vicious double murder OJ
fails to turn himself in now he's on the
Run Bob tour was first on the scene I
got on the radio and I said we' got him
and you know the incredulous people on
the other what do you mean you got him I
said we got OJ that is a phenomenal shot
you were looking at right there as Bob
tur gets Chopper two down very low look
through that back window and perhaps you
can catch a glimpse of OJ Simpson
sitting there OJ Simpson is believed to
be armed and dangerous we are told right
now that OJ sitting there in the
passenger seat with a gun pointed at his
own
head I counted 18 aircraft flying over
the OJ Simpson Pursuit it looked like
something out of Apocalypse Now watching
live was LAPD Detective Tom Lang we saw
the chase on television like everyone
else and I was standing at my desk and
the thought struck me you know we had
his cell phone number went do the
simplest thing in the world and and give
him a phone call I felt that if I were
able to talk to him at this point he'd
talk to me and so I did get a hold of
his number and I did talk to him OJ you
there just let me get to my house okay
we're going to do this I swear I'll give
you what I'll give you I give you my
whole
body we're going to do that just throw
the gun out the
window I wasn't accusatory I didn't
raise my voice I was empathetic with him
on the phone think of your kids please
just toss it out you're scaring
everybody man if I could occupy him
enough on the phone maybe he's not
thinking about shooting himself or
anybody
else please you're scaring us you're
scaring them please man hey you've been
a good guy too man I know you're doing
your job just throw it out the window uh
and nobody's going to get hurt all I did
was love Nicole all I did was love her
thousands of people were lining the
freeways just to get a glimpse of the
motorcade I just wanted to be a part of
history and see if it was really him
driving or what was the hoopla all about
I wanted to see for myself I want to be
there there are people with these
placards raised
up you're innocent you could see people
down the street running to the 405 to go
see it if we really had the internet the
way it is now that would have never
happened people would have just watched
it on their on their cell
phone it was a kind of ghastly parade
kind of hated yourself for watching but
watched anyway I know people that didn't
go on their Hawaiian trip because they
stood at the airport watching The
Pursuit oh who didn't watch the OJ
caret that day more pizzas were sold
than any other day in the history of the
United States so Domino's pizza made out
like Bandits I happened to be in the
Oval Office and met President Clinton
and I want to talk to him about friend
of Science and he said what about that
car CH he didn't even talk about my
books he was too busy talking about OJ
I'm just going to leave I'm just going
to with Nicole that's all I'm going do
that's all I'm to do think about
everybody else all right do a freeway I
couldn't do it in a field I want to do
it at a grave I want to do it at my
own finally after two mesmerizing hours
OJ's white Bronco pulls back into his
[Music]
driveway all right
juice juice come on just toss it juice
would he have used the gun who knows if
you're not going to use it why put
bullets in it after a tense standoff
with police he gives himself
up clearly a big victory once he' gotten
home we have the gun he's in custody
it's all over all the drama's over that
might be the biggest understatement of
the decade we're all involved now we're
all involved in OJ's dilemma and what
might happen ultimately to
him OJ Simpson he is now Far and Away
the most famous murder suspect in modern
American
history the cast of the OJ trial will
soon become household names judge Ido
Johnny Cochran leading the defense
Marsha Clark and Chris Darden for the
prosecution yeah yeah you know we all
became overnight you know rock stars and
as much as we try who could possibly
forget K Kalin half the people thought I
was a witness for the defense when I was
a witness for the prosecution the entire
time um I wasn't really privy to all
these law terms that were going on so
especially when I was called a hostile
witness I didn't even know I thought
hostile to me meant that I I got out of
my chair and I slapped
people the OJ trial plays out amid a
cable TV
Revolution
[Music]
it was called Camp OJ I remember
bringing uh my daughter there and uh
someone tried to sell her a watch with
OJ's car going around the watch dial in
a circle while a police car was
chasing the prosecution is convinced it
has a bulletproof case blood stains in
his driveway and in his automobile in
his hotel room in Chicago Police found
blood on sheets and towels reports said
Simpson had cuts and scratches on his
body the kind of evidence that caused
his defendants to be convicted there was
more evidence against OJ Simpson than
really any murder case I'd ever try to
participate it in Johnny Cochran's
strategy was attack the
LAPD an easy target racial tension in La
is still high it's been only 3 years
since the acqu of the police officers
who beat Rodney King and the LA
riots Johnny cockran knew he could turn
things around and have people buy into
it the media loved it Johnny Cochran
manages to discredit all the evidence by
claiming it was either planted by racist
police or deliberately tampered with
this case is about a rush to judgment an
obsession to win at any cost and by any
means necessary he made the prosecution
look really dumb there were days when I
just wanted it to be over it is
true that firman is racist so many
mistakes made including my
own America is addicted to All Things OJ
are you kidding I was pregnant at the
time of OJ and that was my life you've
got an African-American man you've got
that whole race issue you've got the
Superstar who's now being hauled in and
out every day you've got cable TV coming
of age can you get a fair trial we're
going to try we're going to try we got
do the best we can it was a recipe for
just an American so Opera unlike
anything we've ever
seen the turning point of the trial
comes when the prosecution asks OJ to
try on the bloody glove found at the
crime
scene it was a day that would live in
legal
infamy the glove the glove
fit play the
glove
beautiful just
[Music]
beautiful it doesn't
fit if it doesn't fit you must AC quit
Johnny Cochran
right uh professional legal scholar
amateur
rapper after 8 months of testimony the
jury is called in to give their verdict
we the jury and the aboved entitled
action find the defendant orenthal James
Simpson not guilty of the crime of
murder in violation of penal cult
section
187a a felony upon Nicole Brown Simpson
a human being as charged in count one of
the
information when the verdict was read I
was in the front row of the
courtroom I heard gasps OJ was in
disbelief he scored another touchdown OJ
Simpson Got Away the double
murder OJ Simpson killed two
people no
question many thought the OJ aqu quiddle
was payback for the Rodney King
verdict I just feel like standing on top
of this table and dancing a jig you know
there's a debt to be paid they owe
us they let those officers and see me
valy
go when it was on videotape and when the
guilt was clear there was this idea that
like we've been screwed over so many
times by cops and the justice system
that this is probably the wrong answer
but we'll take
it and in true '90s fashion just about
everybody connected with the case cashed
in girls would come up to me to assign
their breast I got underwear in the mail
at my agency all the time some small
some big
and it was amazing when girls would say
KO do me it seemed impossible that the
9s would ever see a more lurid long
running and mesmerizing real life soap
opera but as we know now the '90s always
had a way of topping
itself I did not have sexual relations
with that woman I was frightened I was
so
frightened
[Music]